first in line good queen tell me about
being out on that stage Oh whoo you
cannot imagine what it's like with that
kind of crowd and that kind of love for
us which is actually pretty powerful
yeah you know people go you really you
haven't done a con until you've done
comic-con bit and I totally get it now
right it was just huge there have been
there have been quite a few terminator
terminator sequels after t2 but for
whatever reason they haven't totally
connected with audience James Cameron is
all for this one what do you think it is
about this one that's really gonna it
has to be a character driven story you
can have all the action in the world but
if you don't have characters that you
care about that are in jeopardy then you
don't care I mean you could just have
the best visual effects in the world but
it really has to start with people and
relationship and I think we brought it
down back to its basic form fewer
characters cleaner story and then all
the souped up special effects I got to
know about the swearing bet I when we
started we I think that they they
definitely were going for a pg-13 but
like in the first week Tim just saying I
had a [ __ ] we were only loved one one of
those F words like first week it was
like it was like well why don't you say
metal mother and why don't you literally
like we're losing the battle and it's
the first week out of 96 shooting days
and then it just became clear that we
could not tell this story without the
f-word so I apologize in advance
fortunately my parents are gone so they
won't have to you know be embarrassed
but it just seems to be really necessary
I mean the audience went nuts just
seeing you and Arnold fighting
side-by-side what was like for you on
set having that moment again I loved
working with Arnold
I actually was just pleased as punch
when I saw him again and it been a
number of years and I just have this
affection for him that is so deep and
abiding that just got completely
cemented on this film I loved working
physically with him I loved seeing him
in the trailer I loved toying with them
you know it's you know the the very top
of a 35-year relationship and that
really means something to me I'm hearing
he couldn't stop quoting himself on set
don't let that's Arnold isn't it that's
Arnold are you gonna adjust to calling
him Carl ever we can't give that as that
spoiler away well just because I have a
friend named and he doesn't know that
there I mean I've said to him there's a
major surprise for you in this film but
we kind of we definitely make that we
pay out that moment later in the film
no spoilers